akisha is with us lakeisha is in newark
new jersey how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
hi um i um i
uh just real quick story um i grew up in
foster care
and um you know i pulled myself
up my by my bootstraps and um
became a teacher um yeah
so i was in a car accident um i think
when i was 19
and i felt bankruptcy when i was 25
because i had all these hospital bills
and i was like oh you know it was only
going to be one time
so what happened was um you know i found
bankruptcy i you know
cleaned up my credit got my finances
together and when i was 40 years old i
was assaulted by a student
in the school and um
i was um suggested that i take early
retirement so i have full pension and
full benefits
um but in the interim of me taking full
attention
and um you know does it take it's a
two-year process to
apply for retirement um um my house was
got in trouble
about chapter 13 to keep the house
and then um i thought after like a year
later has followed another
chapter 13 because i just couldn't keep
up with the payment so
um i i decided just to let the house go
because you know there's no way i can
you know afford this house and um
but then uh you know once they sell the
house i'm probably gonna have like
another
um like a residual uh
you know um loss on it so um should i
file the fourth to get rid of
the uh the debt from the house or i
should just
go with your plan as is you're a hot
mess girl
i mean four bankruptcies oh
my gosh wow
wow i'm so sorry you've been through
hell oh man
um so what kind of mortgage do you have
fha
va or conventional fha
you're not going to have to worry about
a deficit fha does not pursue deficits
is the foreclosure is the foreclosure
underway
yes okay good all right so you're going
to lose the home
where are you going to live um i saved
up
um 3 000 no 2 000 already
so and i live in northern new jersey so
it's very expensive here
so i'm planning on saving up five
thousand [ __ ]
you know move out and get and get up get
a rental
yeah and then get on ramsey plus hold on
we're gonna get you signed up for it and
help you so
yeah we we need to stop at three
bankruptcies that's plenty
let's play you know our last caller with
the coming up on the fourth bankruptcy
um one of the things that stung me
uh left an ouch mark on me when i was
uh going through the bankruptcy was well
actually there were two things they
followed the same heading
one is the bankruptcy attorney actually
gave
some good counsel he said you know
filing bankruptcy does not create an
income
okay yeah so and you got an income
problem right
and you know you don't think about it
because you got all this weight on you
and if i could just get these bills off
of me i'll be okay
but i had an income problem and in that
same heading
is this idea that
um
bankruptcy financial problems
are never really the problem they're
really the symptom
including when i had them yeah the
symptom of something else going on
and so with lakeisha you know
joking around with her but but if you're
continually coming back to this
threshold of crisis yes
multiple times in your life the common
denominator
is you yes sir yes sir i didn't have
enough time to say that i wanted to say
that
you know um and especially when she said
she had to ask that question
like you already knew the answer to the
question because the question the answer
to the question true answer is
what do i need to do so i do not have
this issue moving forward
now that that's that's the true question
that you should be asking yourself
so you never again never i'm never again
gonna be here yep so
what have i got to do to never again be
here yes and
uh you know because otherwise you can't
file bankruptcy enough times to become
successful
it does not bring about prosperity it
really doesn't